19 years after britney popped out of a
wedding cake and
kissed madonna
oops they did it again welcome to
entertainment tonight michelle turner is
off there were stars and some
pre-wedding drama but at the end of the
day brittany and sam made it official
and we've got all the i do details
[Music]
[Applause]
all for her
i just wish her all the love and
happiness in the world
from the cinderella carriage to the
hundreds of roses britney's 10-minute
ceremony with sam felt like a fairy tale
she walked in by herself and it was
can't help falling in love
[Music]
e.t spoke exclusively today to reverend
clint huff he officiated the wedding and
says britain sam kept the vows
traditional it was repeat after me
and
they were just completely locked in on
each other it was amazing there was a
beautiful moment where britney got a
little teary-eyed and sam just reached
up and took care of her with the tissue
the bride rocked four different wedding
day looks and she lit up around her
a-list pals that's britain madonna
recreating their iconic vma kiss then
there was this retro moment strike a
pose there's nothing to it
so who made the guest list and why
donatello versace created the wedding
dress paris hilton was a party girl pal
back in the early 2000s fellow singer
selena gomez sent britt a care package
during her legal battle and drew
barrymore i've actually been sending her
personal videos
we're not quite sure why maria menounos
or ansel elgort showed up that's ansel
watching sam and brit spin on the dance
floor of course britt's family didn't
make the wedding day cut also missing
britney's two sons with kevin fetterline
you know the boys are very happy for her
and they're happy for the
chance for her and sam to have a great
future but you know they it was somewhat
sudden and they were a little
overwhelmed and
this is brittany and sam's night
sam and brittany held hands almost
during the entire ceremony and it seemed
as though that kind of grounded them
into the moment that they had each other
[Music]
paris who sang her famous hit stars her
blind with brittany last night shared
more details on her this is paris
podcast i was actually asked to dj
for the president this was more
important to me it made me so happy to
see that she found her fairy tale
at 10 15 the newlyweds left in a white
rolls royce the bride hiding in the back
of the groom still wearing his black
britney and sam t-shirt as the party
continued without them for another 45
minutes like any special touches that
you could maybe tell us about
oh we'll tell you the pop star's
off-the-shoulder donatella designed
wedding dress had a portrait neckline a
nearly 15 foot long white tulle veil
with hand-sewn satin edging and a stream
of pearl buttons it took 700 hours to
make as for the bling the newlyweds went
all in wearing more than half a million
dollars in diamonds putting in their
order just a few weeks ago we definitely
did a bit of hustling on our end overall
she was wearing i believe it was 62
carats of diamonds for the day we did
make britney a heart-shaped necklace and
engraved her wedding date on the backs
oh i'm here to crash the wedding bro but
britney's big fairy tale day could have
become a nightmare where's britney at
get off
where's britney at hours before the i do
spear's first husband of 55 hours jason
alexander crashed his way onto her
property via backyard trail live
streaming his entire journey entering
her home
and her wedding tent before security
actually intervened my name's jason
alexander brittany invited me here
that's jason being tackled to the ground
sheriffs were called and arrested him
the 40 year old was hit with multiple
charges including trespassing vandalism
and battery matthew brittany's attorney
matthew rosengaard who was seen arriving
to the ceremony hours after the incident
tells e.t it was an outrageous criminal
act i am livid and will ensure he's
aggressively prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law jason remained in jail
overnight here at the ventura county
sheriff's department held on more than
22 thousand dollars bail he's due in
court tuesday
[Music]